So let's begin then in October the 10th 1925
Here we have a an absolutely extraordinary
revelation of
Our blessed mother and Louisa is asked to do the same thing so
Louisa says as I was in my usual state
My poor mind found itself within an extremely high atmosphere
So she's talking about being very deeply immersed in the divine will I seemed to see the divinity
So you can see how high she is in her experience of God and
Upon one knee of the celestial father our Queen mother was dead as if she had no life
Surprised Louisa thought to herself. My mother is dead, but what a happy death to die on the knees of her creator
But looking more closely, I saw her will as though detached from her body held in the hands of the divine father now of course
Blessed mother is not dead
What is being shown to her here is that her will was literally laid at the feet of God
In the first instant of her existence and so she's lying as though dead on the knees of her creator
So amazed Louisa said I looked and I could could not give myself a reason for what I was seeing
But a voice coming from the divine throne said
This is the elect among the elect the krem de la krem
This is it as far as human beings are concerned. You can't get higher than this
She is the all-beautiful one. I don't know how many of you remember the old Latin chants
but one of the ones that I absolutely love and I still sing to myself is
Tota pulkra is Maria. You are all beautiful Mary
And the stain of sin was never in you
Okay, so you are the glory of Jerusalem. You are the joy of Israel. You are the honor of our people
I wouldn't attempt to sing it to you. It'll take too much time
But these are the words
You are the glory of Jerusalem the joy of Israel the honor of our people
They were said to Judith after she killed hollow furnace the great enemy of the people of God at the time and
The church sings them to our blessed mother because she is the one who puts her foot on the head of the snake
The real enemy of God's people. So to call her the all-beautiful
Means that she is full of sanctity in so far as a human being can hold it
She is absolutely what God wants
His creatures to be she's the only creature who gave us her will as a gift and
Left it dead upon our knees in our hands. Now. Why is the Lord saying she's the only creature since
We are on volume 18 and Louisa has been living in the divine will for many many volumes
And she entered into an extraordinary union with God in volume one
So what's the Lord saying what he's saying is that our blessed mother?
Gave her will to God in the first instance of her being that is the difference and
Louisa is
giving her will to God as an adult and you and I some of us are giving our wills to God in our old age
Before we leave the planet, but at least if you get there at all, I think that's really fantastic
That is the difference. It's a difference in the time in your life when you actually make this gift to God
And we that's the most holy trinity in exchange gave her the gift of our will now watch this carefully
That gift was given to her of course in the first instance of her being a
Greater gift we could not give to her because by acquiring this supreme will she had the power to make the
Divine word become incarnate and descend upon the earth
That was because there was a divine will operating in her not just a human will I
He's going to underline that so because of this she had the power to make the
Divine word become incarnate descend upon the earth and to have redemption of mankind formed as a result
Now watch this a human will could have no power or attraction over us
We have no idea how small we are our
Solar system is a speck of a speck in the universe
So there's there's no measurement that I know of for how small we are and I'm not talking about humility or
litmus or anything. It's just this year and
fact of our non-entity as as creatures Samates as a Lord how should you could possibly a
Care for a man. He's absolute nothing and yet you did so much you made him little less than a god a Samate
So a human will would have no power or attraction over us, but a divine will watch this
Given by ourselves to this incomparable creature. She's incomparable because of the extraordinary
situation she had the first instant of her being people nowadays with the horror and terror of
Abortion know nothing about the first instant of one's being they know nothing about it
They won't even acknowledge that it is a child that is developing and a child of God not just a child of man a
Human will would have no power or attraction over us, but a divine will given by ourselves to this incomparable creature one
Os over conquered us in raptured us now you get her our blessed mother speaking about that herself in her
book on
blessed mother in the divine will and
Jesus says we were unable to resist. What are they unable to resist their own divine will operating in and through a creature?
This is the incredibly important thing for us. We couldn't resist
We surrendered to harp and petitions to make the divine word
descend upon the earth
now we come to Louisa and
Louisa is being asked to make the same gift that her will would die now. I know that there are thousands of
People around the world all claiming to be living in the divine will I'd love to know if anybody has left their will dead on the altar
I would be very interested
because
Jesus now says to Louisa now. We're waiting for you. Now. This is volume 18 and
Louisa has had those three mystical marriages in
Volume one
She has had all this purification and all this development since then and all this revelation given to her and it's now
After all this experience that God says lay your will on the altar
This is very important because I think that we can erroneously claim to be further on than we actually are
Just because we have consecrated ourselves to God. That doesn't mean your will is dead on the altar. No way
Just watching the struggles that Louisa has had
In all the volumes leading up to now you can see that her will was quite alive
That she was determined she wasn't having these privations for example
She she was determined he was coming and she wanted him with her and that was that
So now she's being asked to make a burnt sacrifice of her will and this is the final gift to God
Now we are waiting for you to come to die upon our other knee
So the altar of God are the knees of the Father which I think are beautiful giving us your will
Now if I hadn't come across this text I would have presumed she had given her will of
10 12 volumes back
But she had insofar as she was able
But it takes an enormous journey to get to the point where the will will actually
Die and let the divine will take over
Now we're waiting for you to come and die upon our other knee giving us your will and we in
Seeing it dead in our hands as if it no longer existed for you will give you the gift of our will
You see that gift was given to her a long time ago
But here she's coming to the culmination of it in laying down her will
On the knees of the Lord
We will give you the gift of our will and through you that is through this will of ours
Given to you now. He's explained that with regard to our blessed mother that it was the divine will
Given to her as a result of her burnt sacrifice of her will that gave her the power to bring the divine
Word incarnate so this is what he's saying to her as well. It's at this point. He said
When you lay down your will in death on our knees
That's when we will give the kingdom of the divine will
not before that
With all the sacrifices you've made with all the sufferings with all the intercessions with all the struggles with all the
Generosity and everything know this is the point where it actually operates
In seeing your will dead in our hands as if it no longer existed for you
we will give you the gift of our will and through you that is through this divine will of ours given to you our
Fiat will return to the earth that will be the definitive descent of the Holy Spirit upon the church and the world
These two wills that is those of our blessed mother and Louisa dead upon our knees
Will be the ransom for many rebellious wills
Now I want to give you a mark 10 45
two disciples wanted to be on the
First in the kingdom of God and they wanted to be at Jesus's right and on his left in his kingdom
and Jesus said no no those places are kept for the people to whom they are to be given to and
These two people are blessed mother and Louisa the one through whom God was able to bring about the incarnation
And the second one through whom he's able to bring about the kingdom of the divine will and so these two wills dead upon our knees
Will be the ransom from many rebellious wills and we will keep them as a precious pledge or down payment
Which will repay us for all the evils of all the other wills of creatures put together?
Because with our will they will be able to satisfy us
So notice it's the divine will in our blessed mother and the divine will in Louisa that enables this to happen
Okay, so the next paragraph. We have a very important moment in the history of the human race
Louisa said
The voice could no longer be heard and I found myself on the other paternal knee in the act of breathing my last and dying
But at that moment, I found myself inside of myself
She was brought into this depth of understanding of what was going on and then brought out of her ecstasy
So she could do it in her conscious mind
Because it's in our conscious mind that we say Lord. I
Give myself to you. I lay my will at the foot of your altar. I put my will as a burnt sacrifice on the altar of God
It's it's in the absolute consciousness
No special visions or revelations or anything else supporting you you do it of your own free will and that's the gift to God
That's the glory for God that we would do it of our own free will
When you go back into the scriptures you find that
God had a terrible struggle with the human race trying to get his people to do his will he had a few victories along the way
For example, when Abraham put his son on the altar. He was putting his own heart
his own life
His own future all of God's gifts and this one son whom he loved
Everything was laid on the altar of God and that's when God considered him as righteous
Because he had glorified God saying to God
You'll read it in the letter to the Hebrews chapter 11 that he believed that Isaac would be raised from the dead because God could not lie
And God had made these incredible promises about the future. So
What you're looking at there is Abraham trusting God beyond reason and
That's what glorified God
that it is absolute trust in the in the divine one and
so Louisa is brought out of her ecstasy and in the the coolness of
Facing reality
That's when she does it at that moment
I found myself inside of myself and I'm unable to say what I felt within me only
I prayed from the heart that my will would never again enter into me
But only the divine might have life in me that there's the laying down of her will not in the ecstasy
Helped by the vision or helped by
The presence of the Lord. It's when she's back in in the bed and she's back in her old self
That's when she makes the offering and I think that's fantastic
She said the divine will alone is the bearer of all goods and the repeater of Jesus within souls and
Echoing the fiat of creation the divine will embraces everything and everyone as though in one breath
and therefore it requires God for the work of creation redemption and
Sanctification the divine will operating in us can do any thing
now that little word anything is a little test and
You alone can give yourself this test because you know in your everyday life
Whether in fact in the things that happen to you good or bad in your favor
Or not in your favor, you know how you react to them and it's in that reaction
You know whether you're allowing God to operate in everything
everything every second
in every situation
So the divine will is the true queen who reigns and rules over everything
So in the next paragraph then blessed mother speaks to Louisa
Afterwards, she said I saw my celestial mother with the baby Jesus in her arms and she kissed him and placed him to her
Breast to give her most pure milk and I said to her my mother. What about me?
Don't you give anything to me?
Please allow me to at least place my I love you between your mouth and that of Jesus while you kiss him
So that my little I love you can run within everything that you do
So she wants to enter into all of the acts of our blessed mother and so our blessed mother said to Louisa
My daughter, please do place your little I love you
Not only in the mouth
But in all the acts that pass between me and my son. You must know that everything I did towards my son
I intended to do towards those souls who would live in the divine will
That I think you need to highlight
Everything she did for her son. She intended doing for us
That's something you really need to spend time with
Because she said being in the divine will they would be disposed to receive all the acts that I did towards Jesus
And I would find sufficient space in which to place them
So she needs to have people living in the divine will who would actually be open to receive what she wants to give them
And that they would have made enough space in their souls
In order to be able to receive it their souls are not cluttered with sin and self and world and all the rest it goes with it
So blessed mother said if I kissed my son, I also kissed them
Because I found them together with him in his supreme will
They were the first to be as though lined up within him and my maternal love pushed me to
Let them partake in everything now. These are the other children. She acquired at the foot of the cross
Yeah, she acquired everybody
Because she's the mother of the all who believe she's the mother of the church
But not everybody has reached this level of communication with God and reached this openness to receive
And it's so sad. There are so many people you couldn't talk about this to at all
So blessed mother continues great graces were needed for those who would live in this holy will and
I placed all my goods all my graces all my sorrows at their disposal
So we need to be conscious of the fact that not only is blessed mother on our side
but
Everything she has said and done and all of her the acts of her life are all there to help us
And I did this she said as their help, so she's the mother of perpetual help as
Their defense she's the queen of victories as their strength
She's the mother of hope as their support and as their light
And I felt happy and honored with the greatest honors to have as my children the children of the will of the celestial father
So what she's looking for is a whole harvest of children who actually do the will of God because then they will be like their mother
The children who are in rebellion against the will of God are not like their mother
They're not carrying the likeness of the mother and all of you who are mothers know how much you grieve when a child is
Gone in a different direction to the direction the parents know is right for them
she said it was the greatest of honors to have as my children the children of the celestial father and
She said it was that will that I too possessed and therefore I looked at them also as births from me
Very special children the true sons of God
Even more I can say of them what is said about my son?
That the first generations found salvation in the merits of the future redeemer
That is everybody in the Old Testament all of their grace of redemption
It all came from Calvary and even though in the book of Exodus you study the whole plan of
Redemption all the grace that they received all came from Calvary every single bit of it and
you have Jesus with his arms wide open reaching out to the past and reaching out to the future because he's the
Pontifex Mactimus and the people of God walk on his shoulders all the way into heaven and
So the the first generations that's the people of God in the Old Testament
They were saved by the merits of the future redeemer
So next time you're reading Isaiah and Jeremiah and Ezekiel and all of these wonderful people realize that all their grace came from Calvary
Came from one that they knew very little about except for Isaiah he knew an awful lot in the same way these souls
By comparison with the Old Testament way into the future
Okay, two thousand years beyond Christ these souls these future daughters by virtue of the divine
Will operating in them are the ones who incessantly implore
Salvation and graces for all the future generations
So here we are and all the future generations are all depending on us
I think this is the most marvelous thought
There's so much disaster in society today and yet the Lord is asking us through our divine acts
And through our allowing the divine will to operate in us to create a
safe pathway for future generations to come to this earth without abortion
Without child abuse
Without pornography without all the stuff that's destroying our children today to give them a safe pathway
That's Jeremiah 29 11 that you create a future full of hope for them while they are doing their best to destroy humanity today
It's one of the wonderful things about living in the divine will that you have to understand the vision of the future that you
Are not looking at the disaster. You are looking beyond the mountain to see
What can be done to let generations of people live on this earth in the fullness of grace?
They are with Jesus and Jesus is in them
That's those who live in the divine will and they repeat together with Jesus all that Jesus contains
Therefore, if you want me to repeat for you what I did for my son, let me always find you in his divine will
It's very simple
And I will be generous with my favors towards you. It's wonderful
so let's come to
October the 17th 1925 and Jesus talks about the food of
the divine will
What is it that actually enables the soul to grow strong and
Holy and powerful and everything else after two days of most bitter privations, Louisa said
I felt Jesus move in my interior. I seem to see him in my interior sitting with his head
Leaning to one side upon my shoulder with these mouth turns towards mine
In the active administering words to me now, that's very awkward English
We would say he was leaning towards her
Wanting to talk
Wanting to share something with her, but they give you this in the most astounding
Language, I don't know where they get the language from
If this was translated into simpler English, I think the message will be much more directed
So I plastered him to myself
She said which is simple enough and I began to listen to him
Abandoning all of myself and him now. That's the important bit
That you abandon all of yourself to him and when he is speaking to you either through these
Revelations from Louisa or through the scriptures or through the catechism or the teaching of the church that we really are
Like Mary of Magdalene at the feet of Jesus where Jesus said she has chosen the better part
She's opened herself up completely to really listen to the word of God. Okay, so that's what Louisa is doing here
and so when we're
privately reading
This material it's very important for us to fuse in the divine will and enter
Deeply prayerfully into this text and I find there's a great grace in actually just reading it
So it seemed that Jesus was saying to me my daughter my will is more than food
Notice that more than he's going to use food as an example because we understand food
Food gives strength to the body. It warms it. It increases the blood it enlivenes the intelligence
If it is dim I like that one it puts liveliness into all the members of the body and
Pushes the creature to new works and new sacrifices on the other hand if one is on an empty stomach
Really, he's talking about
starvation and
You're going to see that this image is being used for people who are starving themselves spiritually today and
if they're on an empty stomach not
Giving the necessary food to the body
So the body is weak and cold and lacking in blood her intelligence is dim
Exhausted in all her members and this leads her to melancholy
We would call that depression or mood swings and it pushes her to do nothing because she has got the energy
With no desire to sacrifice herself in anything
so notice
huge energy with the food no energy without it
ability to actually do things with food in ability to do anything without it
These are the bits that we need when he goes on to talk about the divine will
So she's not able to do anything or sacrifice herself so poor one she feels her life missing and this is so true that when illness
Is mortal for a creature the creature abandons food and by abandoning food disposes themselves to death
Okay, so now we come to the soul food, which is what he's after the physical food was only an example leading into this
Since the eternal wisdom has established that the soul
To should have food
Now the expression eternal wisdom is actually terribly important because throughout the whole of the Old Testament
God manifested himself as eternal wisdom and
eternal word to the people
So so that when you read St. John's gospel for example
And he tells you that the word became flesh and dwelt amongst us
He actually presents Jesus as divine wisdom as well as they incarnate word the logos
so
Eternal wisdom established that we should have food for the soul as well
And she assigned the supreme will as the delicious food of the soul
Now since the divine will is this delicious food you can see that everything we have just said
about a body
starving to death
Can now be applied to the soul of our society today
So one who takes this food is strong that means spiritually strong
Uh in doing good
And she uses those soaked with love for her god
So one of the signs that we have of a person living in the divine will is that they actually grow in love for god
not just for their neighbor
And so you don't just have a religion
You have a personal relationship to god everything is personal
This food increases the divine blood in order to form the growth of the life of god within her
Like the son it is reflected in her intelligence
To make her know
Now no would include understand
her creator
And be formed in his likeness because you have no understanding he can't cooperate
It puts liveliness into her whole soul
We say her the soul is usually considered as feminine
In order to put all the virtues in force and it pushes her to do new works and sacrifices on her dog
Now we have testimony of 2000 years
That those who came closest to the lord have also done the greatest works for him
And have made the greatest sacrifices and and produced the most extraordinary
things for god
So the food of my will gives itself in every instant
No, no notice this. I've been emphasizing this. It's every nano second
In every instant at each breath at night when you're asleep
during the day
In each thing and as many times as one wants
So don't forget to multiply things to infinity
Nor is there any danger as with corporal food that if you take too much of it you'll get sick
You can't get sick of divine will it's not actually possible
It's the exact opposite in fact
The more one takes of this divine food the more it fortifies and raises the soul to the likeness of the creator
Hence you see in the saints that instead of
shortening the time of prayer they actually lengthen it
One can remain with one's mouth always opened
Like the little birds waiting to be fed in the act of taking this celestial food
But it's all the opposite for one who does not take the food of the divine will for one who doesn't take it at all
Now here you got the real sickness
And unfortunately we have the vast majority of society here and at this particular point for one who doesn't take it at all
It can be said that she disposes herself to die eternally
You really need to take note of that
As for one who seldom feeds herself with the divine will in other words she'll do the divine will every now and then
She's weak and in constant and good. She's cold in love. She's lacking in the divine blood
In such a way that the divine life grows as though anemic with inner
The light of her intelligence is so dim
This is the extremely important thing
The more people go away from the divine will the more blind they become
And they reach the point which our society has already reached that religion doesn't make any sense to them
Only atheism
Makes sense or materialism
Because they are living so far from the divine food
You get a very good reflection on society looking at this
Okay
So the light of their intelligence is so dim that the soul knows little or nothing of her creator
Now it's really sad that we have many Catholics who know little or nothing of their creator and not knowing him
His likeness is so far from her
For as much as she is far away from the food of his will
So the less and less that a person does the will of god the more spiritually sick they become
That's why he said a little bit earlier. They disposed themselves to die eternally. Another was going to mortal sin
The soul is without liveliness and doing good
Because she does not have sufficient food. So the sign of a society moving away from the divine will is that love grows cold
And in our society when I say our society, I'm not
Speaking specifically of one country. I'm speaking about the world
The world today has lost love and has cultivated death
We've been living in the culture of death for a long time
So in this situation patients will escape this person
Charity will grow cold. They won't have charity either
Nor will they have detachment from everything and sometimes detachment from anything
And so the poor virtues live as though strangled without the food of the divine will
And then Jesus said if you could see a soul without this celestial food, you would weep over there
Because you would see there are
So many miseries and you would see the rubbish with which the person is covered when you consider that
We have to leave the earth to go back to god and we have to leave everything
Including our bodies
We go out of the world
absolutely poor
When you consider that and and
think of the
sheer numbers of people who live entirely for material things
It's extremely sad
However, there is more
for
One he's saying it's this is very awkward English
He's saying it's it's much easier to be compassionate and understanding for a person who's dying of physical starvation
Because they mightn't be able to actually get food they might let the money to get food
But that's not the case for somebody who is starving themselves of the divine will
He said because the divine will is given freely to anybody and god is not picky about who actually seeks his divine will
If you seek him that's absolutely fine by him
His divine will is given out completely free
And therefore he says the soul who refuses it and continues to refuse it becomes spiritually sick to the point of spiritually dying
He says they deserve condemnation
because
They have refused something that was given to them freely
Now there's two things I have in mind there and one of them is it's only come to me now. So I don't have the reference
But you'll know it because it's the parable
in which the man
Comes to the wedding banquet without the wedding garment
And the wedding garment will a gift of the king
So if he comes into the wedding banquet
Not having accepted the gift of the king is thrown out
Because it's free
And it was not only free with the personal gift from the king to them
Okay, they deserve condemnation and the condemnation is formed
By the soul themselves
Because she has rejected the food. I said there was two things in my mind and one is gone might come back
So then louisa said afterwards
I heard that various people had suffered contrasts and humiliations and other things and my sweet jesus
Resume speaking my daughter. He said just as the body contains bad blood
This actually amused me when I was reading it because the description of medicine here is not the description of medicine today
It's the description of medicine a couple of hundred years ago
It's absolutely amazing. I just wonder if if doctors were still behaving like this during louisa's time
Maybe it's just ignorance on my part, but I would be amazed that they hadn't advanced a little bit more
So he said just as the body contains bad blood which infects the good one
You mean bad bacteria
And it's necessary to to apply vesicants
Well, whatever they are. I all I know is that they cause blisters
Leeches bloodletings in order to draw out the bad blood. How would you know by making a hole in the body that there was bad blood that was coming out?
They said we're good
So in order to draw out the bad blood, but he's going to use this as an image
Otherwise one is in danger of remaining paralyzed for the rest of one's life
In the same way the soul who lacks the continuous food of my will contains many bad humors
Okay, and it's necessary to apply the vesicants of humiliations
In order to draw out the bad humor of self esteem
You see the thing that really opposes the divine will
Is the self is the human will and
Modern society glorifies itself
It's into autolotry that is the worship of itself, which is the final insult to god
So the lord has to let things happen
So that the self esteem gets a bit of a dent
The bites of leeches in order to extract the infected humor of the vain glory
Of one's own self that the vain glory is self worship
immediate bloodletings to block and draw the
The bad blood of the little attachments this one is interesting
If you go to the song of songs chapter two verse 15
You have the author
putting words on the
Lips of the bridegroom
Let us go into the vineyard and catch the little foxes that destroy the vineyard
Now the little foxes that destroy the vineyard if you're living in the divine will are these attachments
Now you may say to yourself. I'm not attached to such and such a thing, but just let someone take it off you
So you have this beautiful pen that somebody has given to you
And somebody just else decides that they're they like it and they walk off with it
You learn pretty quickly whether you're attached to it or not
And we can be attached to all kinds of things
You know my favorite doctor or my favorite hairdresser or my favorite whatever and of course you're not attached to them
It's just that if something happens and you can't have them you suddenly discover. Oh
I was leaning on them a bit
And so the little attachments are actually harder to deal with than the big ones because the big ones you can actually see them
The little ones are much more difficult
So the lord says he has to he has to block and draw out the bad blood of the little attachments
Which she keeps forming in her heart towards the people whom she approaches in doing good
That's very interesting. That means that
If the lord is using me to teach other people that I sort of want them as mine
You know, they're my students. I teach them
So you see that the lord couldn't allow that because
It would destroy me and this bad attachment would actually be a block to the people who are listening to me as well
So we we've got to do what saint arrays did go to god with empty hands
But the little attachments are difficult and you can see
in talking about
bits of self-esteem and bits of vain glory and bits of little attachments why
Even though you're giving yourself to the divine will all this time
It can be much further down the line when the lord would confirm the gift because all of this stuff has got to be dealt with
I would prefer I think to give you an image of cleaning a house
And it's okay to do the overall bits and you can make the thing look okay
It's much more difficult to get into all the nukes and crannies and get behind all the
The boxes and wherever else you have in the place and open all the drawers and and empty them out and clean them all
That's different now. That sounds like spring cleaning in not awfully
Excited about that
But that's the kind of spring cleaning the lord has to do in our souls
And this is why reaching the point of having the the gift confirmed can take time
Otherwise, Jesus says those humors would grow so much as to infect everything that she does
In such a way as to remain paralyzed and good for the rest of her life
Poachers always do good. I think this is fantastic
They are the centuries of the heart
Which maintain the blood pure that is the intention
Of the soul upright in doing good
Therefore if all did good only in order to fulfill my will punctures wouldn't be necessary
Because my will is the safeguard against all bad humors. So punctures are also the penalties that are
For those who don't really take
The divine will so notice what when the lord allows
And little bits of trials and difficulties and and so on
It's because
There's stuff in the nukes and crannies of our soul that need to be uh spring cleaned and got out of the place
Now october the 21st 1925 is all about the effects of the one
Act of the divine will
Okay, lovely stuff here. So louisa says this morning oncoming my sweet jesus told me my daughter
I bring you the kiss of all heaven. I there's absolutely a fantastic thing to tell her
And as he was saying this he kissed me in the name of all the saints and all the angels in heaven
And as he was doing it, he said all of heaven is in my will and because they are in this supreme will
Whatever I do they feel the echo of my act and as though responding to my echo they repeat what I do
Having said this he disappeared and then after a few hours he came back and he said my daughter
Returned to me the kiss I gave you in other words. Everybody in heaven was looking for a return
I think it's it's really beautiful because if love isn't a complete circuit
It's it's wrong
Love goes out
And then the one who receives it must send it back
And god has created us god who is infinite eternal absolute love has created all of us
And everything in love and since we are intelligent creatures
With the gift of free will he expects that the love that has come to us will go back to him freely
That it hasn't got to be pulled out of us
And so he comes he's he's doing this to her louisa doesn't need this lesson this lesson is for us
And so jesus is teaching us through louisa that we must give the return of love
We must respond to what has been given to us
So my daughter returned to me the kiss I gave you because all of heaven my mother
Our celestial father and the divine spirit are all waiting for the requite love your kiss
Because since an act of theirs has come out in my will towards the creature who lives in the exile
They are in further requite love it to be returned to them in my same will
It's one thing for people not living in the divine will to just say thank you lord
It's quite another matter all together to send back the love and the thanks
In the divine will that's a different battle altogether. You're sending it out on the same channel in which it came to you
So as he drew his mouth close to mine almost trembling. I gave him my kiss
Why is she trembling because she's often kissed him before she is very conscious of the fact that the father the holy spirit
Blessed mother all the angels all the saints everyone in heaven wants it
I gave him my kiss. She said and it produced a harmonious sound now hold just
Remember that for a minute and hold on to it
Produced a harmonious sound never before heard which rose up high and diffused in everything and everyone of course because it's in the divine
will
And Jesus with unspeakable love added how beautiful are the acts in my will
And you don't know the power the greatness the marvel of even one act of my will
Now you do not know that means you don't grasp you're doing the act you're
Doing what you've been told to do, but you don't realize
What you're actually doing
You may think you do
But here's Louisa after 18 volumes
receiving this
tugging from the lord to enter much more deeply into realizing what she's actually doing
How beautiful are the acts in my will if you only
You do not know he said the power now
What do you mean by power because we've just been told that
Because the divine will was actually resident in our blessed mother that she had the power
To bring down the divine word to become incarnate upon the earth
And louisa has been invited to join her in letting her will die on the knees of the father
so that
Now having a divine will absolutely operating in her that the holy spirit can descend upon the earth for the era of sanctification
That's the power
the greatness
Redemption
Antification and the marvel of this act this one act in my will this act moves everything heaven and earth changes all history
as if they were one single act and all creation the angels the saints give and receive
The return of that act therefore an act done in my will cannot be without a return
Otherwise all would feel the sorrow of a divine act which has moved everyone
Everyone putting of his own into it and yet not requited now
The everyone in this case is all of heaven. Jesus said I bring you the kiss of all of heaven
So now he's got to bring back to heaven the kiss of the earth through louisa
So that they are they are requited
So the operating of the soul
in my will
Is like the silvery sound of a vibrant and shrill bell now to me shrill isn't pretty
And yet you want to be told in a moment that it is sweet
So whether that word shrill is a slightly misinterpretation or not
I don't know but it seems to have shrill doesn't seem to fit with silvery harmonious and sweet
Okay, so it's like a silvery sound of a vibrant and shrill bell which sounds so loudly as to call the attention of all
So maybe the shrill is the loud sound
Which he said it's very sweet. So it shouldn't be shrill
All that that all recognize at that sound the operating of the soul in my will
All receiving the glory and the honor of a divine act. Okay. Now he's saying to her that when we do an act in the divine will
It has a very special musical sound in heaven
And it is received by all the heavenly dwellers as a very special musical note
In other words, it is completely different to all other communications from the earth
Very very interesting. So it's just emphasizing them the the beauty and the the power
So in the next paragraph then louisa moves to talk about
sorrow and entering into the sorrow of jesus
I was continuing the fusing of myself in the divine will she said I was feeling sorrow for each offense
Which had ever been given to my jesus now this centering into the divine will at a very deep level
From the first to the last man that would be upon the earth
And while feeling sorrow now notice this is not just a prayer that she's praying. She's actually experiencing the sorrow
while
Feeling sorrow. She said I asked for forgiveness
But while I was doing this I said to myself
My jesus my love it's not enough for me notice. She said I said to myself. She's actually talking to the lord
My jesus my love it's not enough for me to feel sorrow and to ask for forgiveness
But I would like to annihilate any sin
so that you may never ever be offended again
And jesus moving in my interior said my daughter
I had a special sorrow for each sin and upon my sorrow hung the pardon
of the sinner look at that
let's entering into the divine will entering into jesus sorrow and
He said upon my sorrow hung the pardon of the sinner
Now this sorrow of mine he said is suspended in my will
waiting for the sinner when he offends me
So that when he feels sorrow for having offended me
My sorrow will descend to feel sorrow together with his and allow the forgiveness to happen
So the human sorrow must combine with this divine sorrow
Okay, so that it has this power for the divine forgiveness to come
But how many offend me and don't feel sorrow
Unfortunately, we're living in society today when it's legal to offend the lord
It's legal to sin
So my sorrow and my forgiveness are suspended in my will and as though I salate it
Thank you my daughter for coming into my will to keep company with my sorrow and with my forgiveness
That's one of the lovely things you see in the hours of the passion
That luisa helps us to actually accompany jesus in his sorrow and in all of his actions in the
The passion including his forgiveness
Please continue to go around in my will and making my sorrow your own cry out for each offense
Sorrow forgiveness with every breath
So that I may not be the only one who feels sorrow and who calls for forgiveness
But I may have the company of my little daughter of my will who feels sorrow together with me
So here the lord is actually
Asking us to join him to enter in and to be part of this forgiveness of everybody now in the world
We're living in today. It needs forgiveness from god in order to survive if we're not to self annihilate
And so I think this message tonight is
utterly and completely timely for us
And the challenge for each one of us is to enter into that sorrow and forgiveness of the lord
And to let that sorrow and forgiveness put a blanket of redemption on the world today to save as many souls as possible
before we destroy everything. So we'll stop there frick night.